The answer is that scaling and translation transforms are being done. There are
two ways to solve this problem. One is to look at the matrix and see if there
is some sort of scaling and translation happening. The other is to realize what
the transform is doing. It's defining a regular box in space by making it a
different size along each axis, that's a scale, and by moving its origin
elsewhere, that's a translation. Notice that if the left is equal to the
negative of the right, which is the common case, the x translation value will
be zero. Similarly, if the bottom limit is equal to the negative of the top,
the y translation value is also zero. This means the box is centered along the
negative z view axis, and so doesn't need to be translated in these directions.